[Music]
we gave 80 million votes
to the man who needs notes yep there's a
lot of stake and he's barely awake
and although his answers weren't
rehearsed his cheat sheet
made it worse telling you man this is
the first dr seuss show in history
that does the news over the weekend
president biden gave us what may be the
weirdest presidential moment since
fdr did donuts on the south lawn
during a stop at a pie shop in michigan
where he was asked about the massive
cyber attack that hit over 200 u.s
companies
on friday with the most recent
hack by the russians would you say that
this
this means we're not sure it's the
russians
as i was on the plane that's why it was
late getting off the plane
uh i'll be in better shape to talk to
you about it
the idea first of all we're not sure who
it is for sure
but what else you need oh nothing you're
all set
oh my god
now in his defense
i'm holding back maybe he knows he's
being filmed
but the cards make him look feeble and
lost
it's like every old relative when
they're doing the tip and for a while
the media made sure
no one saw that which is the same as if
nicole wallace had covered it
it's true they buried it faster than my
dad buried jimmy hoffa
sorry dad but while joe's cognitive
skills are dropping
the media prefers his dessert toppings
oh look he's eating more ice cream
everyone isn't that adorable
not like trump when he had the audacity
to ask for two scoops at the desert
course he gets
two scoops of vanilla ice cream with his
chocolate cream pie
instead of the single scoop for everyone
else
two scoops two scoops for me please
tweeted one critic so the whole
dominance thing extends to desserts too
uh cnn in their better days
remember what a big deal that was but at
least trump could answer a question
ask joe any question it's like he just
went 12 rounds with corn pop
what gives joe notes
i don't need any notes come on man i
don't need
any notes and you can take that to the
bank
i don't need any notes
cat that's not a good look right like if
putin's tuning in and he probably is
and he's seeing the president basically
tell this lady
his strategy and the strategy is on a
notepad
or on notes well what really was even
the strategy like i was so baffled by
and i also watched this video
several times i was so baffled by how
he's like well i don't know any
then he pulls out the notes and he goes
yeah well uh we we don't know like are
you carrying around
a piece of paper that says i don't know
yes cause i think you'd be able to
remember that one
yes yeah although i will say that i do
that on the five a lot i have a lot of
notes and sometimes i write what the
hell am i doing
and then i by accident i'll actually say
it katie what
what kills me is that our government is
spending more time trying to arrest
grannies and red hats
from the capital then actually going
after uh these uh ransomware people
it's like they don't they know exactly
what to do about the the crazy guy and
the
and the horns on january 6. but they
can't figure out what to do with these
uh hackers well first of all
this video is the reason why people
think the election was stolen because i
mean watch the video and you're like
this guy is not prepared for this he
says i'll be in better shape tomorrow
like he didn't train enough for
a marathon right right or something and
then he's like
we oh they told me to read these notes
to
you and it's like who is we yes like you
are the president
of the united states of america you're
supposed to be the guy
telling us all this stuff and you write
about the ransomware stuff i mean he
gave them a list
yeah like please don't please don't hack
these 16 critical infrastructures
that would be really bad and yeah
they're like going after that that's a
great question yeah i didn't even think
of that because if they if they
if they did it friday we have to compare
what they did friday
see if they're the same yeah because
maybe they maybe they listened to biden
and decided oh we're just going to do
everything else outside the list
and then we'll do that list at the end
exactly
all right joe uh did this fill you with
fear
or sadness that that car probably said
inspected by number 12 and it's been in
his jacket for a couple of years
i i'm imagining putin watching this
and just he probably ripped his shirt
off like hulk hogan when he saw this he
was so excited
he's reminiscing over how he killed 50
men with a paper clip
and and our president they're like ooh
what kind of dessert will he have
next yes he couldn't even order a pie
there's an expression easy as pie
and he became confused during the pie
eating and ordering process
so we're in trouble it's going to be a
big mess for president harris to clean
up in about two oh and then we're really
screwed yes yes in two months
tyrus uh how did you feel when you saw
this video
okay first of all um you should never
i have a one track mind myself so i'm
gonna sympathize with the president here
i mean come on man if i'm trying to
focus on which pie to buy
and you're gonna lay some brushes on me
i'm gonna have some problems too i'm
trying to decide between cherry
they got strawberry rhubarb that only
comes in a certain time of the year
but i'm really a lemon meringue pie and
while i'm trying to figure out and check
the list see what everybody at home
wants
and then you're gonna hit me with the
russian like you bro you see i'm getting
pies right here that isn't true
what's wrong with you that's true this
is a this is a pie shop
do you see a world atlas in here
somewhere
it's not it's it's not it's not come on
it's not his fault
everyone knows when joe's mind's on pie
it stays on
can't be confusing him with world
questions when he's getting pie
yeah that'd have been me i'd have been
like what is your name get her out of
here yes
i yeah you you made me come around cause
like when i'm thinking about food i
can't think about anything else you want
me to hack it i'm
a matter of fact he couldn't even he was
trying to remember how much each pie
cost yes
he had the little envelope his wife gave
him with the 3.65
and he was allowed and each pie was a
dollar ten how many pies could joe buy
and so joe was like well i can give
three of this can you ask me about
russia
i'm counting like leave them alone sorry
i'm sensitive about my pie
i understand up next hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else